what did the plate say to the other
plate this one's on me you can't open
your Twitter app these days app without
reading a tweet from the President of
the United States running down the
Russia investigation q dramatic reading
the Russia witch-hunt hoax started as
the insurance policy long before I even
got elected is very bad for our country
they are entrapping people for
misstatements lives or unrelated things
that took place many years ago nothing
to do with collusion a Democrat scam
quote judge Ken Starr former Solicitor
General and independent counsel just
stated that after two years quote there
is no evidence or proof of collusion and
further that there is no evidence that
there was a campaign financing violation
involving the president Thank You judge
at Fox News and finally quote remember
Michael Cohen only became a rat after
the FBI did something which was
absolutely unthinkable and unheard of
until the witch-hunt was illegally
started they broke into an attorney's
office why didn't they break into the
DNC to get the server or a crooked
office all of that was just a single day
in December on Twitter for Donald Trump
and a Sunday to boot now it doesn't take
Sigmund Freud to see that president
Donald Trump is totally obsessed with
the investigation into Russia's
interference in the 2016 election being
run by former FBI director robert muller
now whether that obsession is born from
genuine frustration with an
investigation he believes has nothing to
do with him or a fear that Muller has
already uncovered much and that there's
still more to uncover isn't immediately
clear but here's something we do know no
matter what motivates Trump to talk talk
talk tweet talk about Russia fewer and
fewer people actually believe what he
says here it is a Wall Street Journal
NBC News poll released in mid-december
showed that just 34 percent of people
believe that Trump was being honest and
truthful about the rush investigation
more than six in 10 so they simply did
not believe Trump was being honest about
it that is not an isolated poll either
in a CNN survey released earlier in
December a majority of Americans 54%
said that most of the things Trump has
said publicly about the rush
investigation are false just 36% said
that trumps comments and tweets are
mostly true take a step back I can't I'm
sitting in a chair but consider what I
just said a guy who spent a decade
running the FBI and who was appointed to
that job by one Republican president and
one Democratic president is now in
charge of a special counsel probe into
Russia's active interference in the 2016
presidential election
now that investigation has already
produced a whole hell of a lot a hundred
and ninety two criminal charges against
36 people and entities seven people have
pled guilty and four people have been
sentenced to jail now the President of
the United States despite all of that
continues the Bosch investigation as a
witch-hunt and a hoax despite offering
absolutely zero evidence to make that
case and this is the really important
part a majority of Americans do not
believe the president is telling all of
the truth or even most of it when it
comes to the mower investigation now
that should be a very big deal and yet
because this is Donald Trump we're
talking about the idea of how a
president should act up to and including
whether they should you know tell the
truth seems to have disappeared in
Trump's Legion of Lies consider this the
Washington Post fact checker blog
counted nearly 6,500 6500 false or
misleading statements made by Trump in
just his first 649 days in office that's
a rate of nine point nine totally or
partially false statements every day
Trump has been president including
Sundays huh now what's even more
remarkable yes there's something more
remarkable is that the longer he spends
as president the more distortions and
lies he piles into each day during the
run-up to the
eighteen election Trump was cresting
sixty or seventy falsehoods a day on a
single day in September Donald Trump
said 125 false or misleading things a
hundred and twenty five now the sheer
pace and quantity of Trump's fibbing and
worse is simultaneously astonishing and
hard to follow there are just so many
myths truths and distortions and yet on
the most important issue of his
presidency Russia people seem to be on
to Trump or at least a majority of them
are on to him they don't believe what he
says about the Russian investigation
Muller or much of anything else related
to the attempts of a foreign country to
influence our election no matter how
many times he says tweets it which is a
good thing most people get it except
well these two things number one a lot
of people like somewhere between a third
and 40-ish percent of the country don't
get it
these are the hardcore Trump base and
they believe what everybody tells them
to believe especially if it includes a
shot at the so-called fake news no
matter what Moeller's report on Russia
says once it eventually comes out these
people simply will not believe it
no matter how convincing the proof no
matter how much proof if any there is no
sale for them point number two the very
fact that a majority of Americans think
Trump isn't telling the truth about the
Russia investigation doesn't mean they
view those falsehoods as a deal-breaker
it's a deal-breaker ladies when it comes
to voting for him in 2020
why because voters have never believed
Trump was honest check these numbers out
just one in three in the 2016 election
said Trump was either honest or
trustworthy but here's the truly jarring
thing of the 64% of voters who said
Trump wasn't honest or trustworthy in
2016 one in five cast a ballot for him
anyway which suggests that Trump may
have devalued truth to the point where
people neither expected from him nor
punished him for not adhering to it and
that is the slightly depressing point we
knew this every week twice a week check
out hot new content every Tuesday
thirst